my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we'll have an F in them somewhere
in the middle of this video hello
everyone I'm Milano or Charles and
welcome to my channel and today we are
doing another gaming q a I have a
separate Channel where I do a q a that's
about like everything else and this one
is going to be all about my time playing
Street Fighter 6 though I did want to
know it I only actually got to play uh
local versus I didn't get to play with a
lot of the things people ask me
questions about like story mode so all I
can speak to is how versus plays but I
will try to cover that as thoroughly as
I possibly can because I really enjoyed
it also I'll leave a link in the
description to the full VOD if you want
to see uh my full like hour plus playing
the game live on the Capcom Fighters
twitch Channel a very big thank you to
Capcom for having me also before we go
any further boxing match coming very
very soon very soon now I'm just gonna
be wearing it in my whole video my fight
is a month away and I kept thinking
about how many things in Street Fighter
6 were actually not that dissimilar to
boxing training which is very cool
Joshua asked how did sf6 feel great
question
it really made me feel like Cami no I
think Street Fighter 6 does a very good
job of being Street Fighter and feeling
like Street Fighter but giving you new
things to think about in fact I think
that street fighter has always been
quite good at this um they iterate very
well in my opinion and in the case of
Street Fighter 6 they've combined
basically a bunch of different things
that came from previous Street Fighters
or at least this is the way I see it
again and found the things that work and
put them all into sf6
the Parry system is very similar to the
one that's in Street Fighter 3 third
strike Focus attacks are obviously from
Street Fighter 4 and then there are V
skills which are from Street Fighter 5
and it still has its own very unique
very specific Focus which is very much
on the drive gauge um which is something
that I initially when I was playing was
not paying anywhere near enough
attention to and you can really really
mess up by ignoring your drive gauge
it's a really important basically energy
consumption Meetup it's actually
probably the most significant change in
my opinion to Street Fighter 6 and I
keep saying in my opinion because a lot
of you who follow my channel will know
this but I think this is important
context for anyone who's maybe new uh
watching this video I used to play a lot
of fighting games my favorite fighting
games are actually um all of us as
Capcom by a mile but I also really love
Soul Calibur and I've also always really
liked Street Fighter less of a Mortal
Kombat person uh the controls just don't
gel with me as well but I stopped
playing fighting games for a really long
time because
um big reason why I am such an advocate
for excess ability and why I created the
video game accessibility Awards is that
I have tendonitis in both of my wrists
so any rapid button mashing I basically
can't do it ruled out several genres of
video games I have trouble with fighting
games I have trouble with things like
Guitar Hero because the the thumb
strumming and anything that's like
really fast hack and slash that doesn't
have accessibility I basically can't
play because my thumbs will like freeze
up and get swollen and really hurt
um Real Testament to not playing too
many video games that use your thumbs
too much so Street Fighter 6 modern
controls really really excited me
because it seems to me like a way to
play fighting games with less input uh
and still actually be able to play
competitively it's not like just a baby
auto play mode where you have no input
at all and you could win without
thinking that is definitely not the case
there's a lot of things that I really
still have to think about um just with
reduced button input so I really really
enjoyed it and I again keep giving that
context because while I have played a
lot of fighting games in my time it's
been a while since I've played them like
extensively and I would not consider
myself an expert so so this is the the
best opinions that I can give as
somebody who is not like incredibly up
to date with the latest fighting games
uh but yeah the drive gauge is really
important and where I kept making
mistakes initially because I wasn't
paying enough attention to it and in
fact the drag gauge is basically just as
important as your health bar it gives
you access to a bunch of really powerful
stunts and moves and if you have no
energy or you're depleting your energy
there at the wrong time or maybe you use
uh some of your drive gauge with a move
that ends up being canceled out by your
opponent that can basically lose you a
whole match so I really feel like um
Street Fighter six you know I'm sure
that you could get through a match just
button matching if you wanted to
um I imagine a lot of people will be
doing that online but for the most part
it feels like a game of chess in a way
that I really really appreciate it's
it's really requires you to think and of
course all fighting games do but I think
like having that uh gauge bar really
added to that part of the experience
made a way that I really really really
appreciate it it is time to talk about
keeps which is a subscription service
that helps men keep their hair before I
agree to even work with keeps I
consulted with a whole bunch of friends
who use the product and every single one
of them says that they would recommend
it and recommended that I talk about the
products so that people know there are
options available because it's obviously
very common in fact two out of three
guys will experience hair loss by the
time they're 35 and keeps office
clinically proven research back
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth there is no magic cure for
boldness but with keeps you get quality
expert care all keeps treatment plans
are recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy keeps is FDA
approved provider recommended and offers
24 7 care and support with a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality each
treatment plan actually comes with a
full year of unlimited messaging so you
can connect with your medical provider
about anything anytime so whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair you have keeps has you covered
hair loss stops with keeps to get a
special offer go to keeps.com Alana
Pierce or click the link in the
description that's ke eps.com Alana
Pierce outside of that it feels great I
think the animation is fantastic I
really like all of the levels I love the
colors um I know some people went so
hard on the colors from the questions
that I got but I really love the style I
think it looks fantastic and the drive
gauge
um again is very important and I think
important even in terms of your kind of
situational awareness which is
definitely important for certain
characters in Street Fighter 6 uh Drive
Rush is one that really allows you to
close distances which can be very
important for certain characters
obviously depends who you choose to play
as I was playing as Ryu
um specifically because Ryu is pretty
tanky requires less button input so
again really great for me uh basically
goes hand in hand with any accessibility
needs that I have which is awesome and
drive Rush is the drive gauge ability
for Ryu that allows you to really close
the gap
um and just really rush into someone
which is awesome but it does also use a
lot of Drive gauge so if you mess it up
it would be kind of devastating or if
you time it wrong it would be kind of
devastating so yes the most simple way
to answer how does it feel uh is
tactical and smart
and very very very satisfying I had a
fantastic time playing it I really
really really enjoyed it I think this is
probably my my favorite Street Fighter
in a while uh but also modern controls
enabled me to play
a lot longer than I've been able to play
fighting games for a while but yeah the
thing about drag gauge is that you know
if you run out um you can have reduced
speed I think you even have reduced
defense and then if somebody uses their
Drive Impact which is totally one of my
favorite moves that I saw the whole time
and tried to use wherever I could we had
a moment where I was playing um that we
both use Drive Impact at the same time
which is so explosive and cool and like
has to be hitted exactly the right time
for us to cancel each other out and we
managed to do it once which is like so
devastating for both players but so
exciting that like we actually did the
exact same thing at the same time but
yeah if you run out of Drive gauge
somebody else's Drive Impact is going to
really mess you up so yeah it's just uh
I don't know I think it's a really smart
approach to making sure that even the
most beginner player is thinking about
that meter rather than just spamming
moves they're really thinking about
which to use and when
um rather than just like this combo this
combo this combo you really have to
think about it being a little bit more
in depth and I really appreciated that
about it as somebody who hasn't played
fighting games in a minute that I was
very quickly and easily kind of drawn
into to that tiramisu Mochi asked how
big is the roster for Street Fighter 6
also I'm jealous you got to try it uh
yeah I've actually played it twice by
the way um I played it last year as well
as Chun Li but not for very long because
it was at a public event and I didn't
want to take time away from too many
people
um the florosta was revealed and it's 18
characters I believe oh so I've played
as chinley and Ryu and this most recent
trip I played against Kimberly and I
loved her she's definitely
um doesn't hit quite so hard as um a boy
Ryu but she's very fast and also just
like I love the animation style and the
Sass of this character I I thought she
was so cool that I almost didn't want to
beat her up so you pop culture saying
what modes did you try for Street
Fighter six so I just tried
um versus uh but yes I was playing with
modern controls and I guess I should
talk about that for anyone who doesn't
know what modern controls are Street
Fighter 6 still has classic controls
which would uh play the same as every
other fighting game I think modern
controls are much more appealing to
audiences who probably haven't played
fighting games before basically it takes
away the need for you to memorize all of
those combos which can be a really
daunting thing about getting into a new
fighting game One controls limit the
amount of button presses
um dramatically the combos are easier to
remember or um shorter essentially it's
not that you can necessarily input them
that much faster than somebody playing
on classic and what I asked before how
they were going to balance people
playing classic with people playing
Modern online they aren't intending to
have separate lobbies but the answer I
was told was that they think people
playing classic will still have more of
an edge because they have a little bit
more control it's a little bit more
specific
um but modern controls basically I think
are a really good entryway to get into
classic controls if that's something
that you would want to do again it just
reduces the amount of inputs needed so
you don't have to press as many buttons
or ultimately you don't have to memorize
as many combos it's a lot easier to
remember the combos in modern controls
instead of like three directions and and
three X's you're just going R2 XXX
and that is a full combo uh which is
awesome but it didn't make me go oh this
made the game way easier
um it didn't have that effect what it
instead did was make me excited to get
back to Classic actually I probably
can't for accessibility reasons but for
most people I think that's probably the
effect that it'll have is that you'll
play Modern and you'll learn the move
sets and then when you you know you're
playing by yourself you're practicing
you'll look at the classic Combos and
you'll go oh so that's this one in
modern okay it's just slightly more
inputs it just makes it a little bit
more uh complex in terms of the combos
that you have to remember for each
character playing with modern is
probably a really great way to figure
out which character you want to play as
as well like if you're new to Street
Fighter you could try all of the
characters in modern controls find out
which one you like the most and then you
could
um level up by playing that character in
classical learning it's classic controls
or combos so that you can kind of get
more into the nitty-gritty of that
character so yeah modern is basically a
slightly simplified version of classic
doesn't mean that you can steamroll
somebody you still have to think about
the space and your drive gauge and when
you're timing certain things etc etc
um that's still obviously really
important there's a lot of tactical
requirements to win a match but
definitely something that I think should
be appealing to a lot of new players I
highly recommend it okay well I do have
a couple more Street Fighter 6 questions
I actually think I've answered my
answers was so thorough
that I think I might have covered pretty
much everything I can but yeah I really
I really really enjoyed it I thought it
was awesome and I think that is probably
all we have time for today thanks for
hanging out everybody
um I'm Alana I will see you next month
if you have any questions about video
games you can leave them in the comments
below
this time next month I will be boxing
in exactly a month will be my fight
um that's wild
April 15th everybody
I'm not ready